the class we grapple with people who
give their time who give their talent
and their treasure to changing the world
as they see it when you married Gabe the
riches which was the first gay marriage
in Los Angeles and the mayor of Los
Angeles married you did you see that as
also a political act that you were
giving it was a philanthropic moment we
are you thought of the ramifications
related to that yes in our case it very
much was we had decided to get married
about nine months earlier before it was
clear at all that marriage was going to
be legal in the state of California and
so actually we had a wedding planned for
friends and family a spiritual wedding
or religious even if you will because my
rabbi was going to perform the ceremony
who we love and we were doing it and
Telluride Colorado which is a place that
we go to a lot in love and then suddenly
the wedding was scheduled for July and
then in May suddenly the Supreme Court
ruling comes down and marriage is legal
in the state of California which was you
know extraordinarily exciting to us that
whoa wait a minute now we're actually
getting it legally married which then we
quickly learned that the you physically
have to get married in the state so
actually our Colorado wedding was not
going to have any legal significance
which is when we realize that we also
have to get married in Los Angeles which
is weird because straight people don't
have to do that but you know it's
constantly sort of evolving of you know
you of where we are on the full equal
human rights spectrum